i think this be the biggest light
how tupac the biggest [ __ ] was i think
that's the biggest like
b for whatever you want to call it
that's going on right now though cause
you got every like everybody responding
everybody making songs everybody putting
their two cents in
everybody picking inside is blackballing
you talking about the dirk uh the young
boy man there's so much going on like
people die obviously wanna die yeah it's
just a lot of going on that [ __ ] like
this dude what confuses me
is that
they're not from the same city they're
not from the same hood
uh it feels like actual rat beef like
it's like what are y'all really beefing
about is it about like you know what i'm
saying as opposed to like well somebody
died or not it's over no no no now but
even then it's like quando rondo and
king vaughn are from
three and a half hour flight away from
each other four out like what the [ __ ]
is like going on where like
[ __ ] really get to the point
where
it's it gets so disrespectful
blood gets shed
and
y'all ain't even from the same area this
is y'all wouldn't even know who each
other were from work for rap music yeah
like that's to me the [ __ ] that really
be i'll be seeing some of this [ __ ] to
be like
like i'm i'm not the biggest young boy
fan uh i mean i i like some of his [ __ ]
but i'm not like
i don't like his antics and sometimes
i feel like um there's just so much
unnecessary negative energy bro and
you know i think that's why when you and
i talked last time you were here
it was like dope to see you kind of
opening your minds and not being
so many people i think when i told them
i was talking to you that was the first
thing they associated you with yeah was
that negative [ __ ]
and you know to talk to you i mean what
it's been like seven or eight months
later to see you in a better space it's
good it's good to see man
even with uh
he probably thought i was a [ __ ] up
person he got to meet me he was like you
really you cool right no i ain't expect
that for you like it just you got to
meet somebody and like feel they vibe
you don't know for the judge a person
because no i'm saying you get a
different vibe when you're on somebody
while you're really a good hearty dude
he got a good soul you know what i'm
saying you can feel people energy that's
real how how how would you gauge
academic synergy
all right
i'd expect him to be like how he was
like personal person like he was really
how you would give me advice on
i want to see you alive i want to see
you do this i want you to he was doing
the same thing and i respect that
because you ain't just talking about
just all the beef you want to see me
make it as far as like as a man you know
what i'm saying you want to see me grow
you understand
i respect